[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
اخباريه الخاص ومتنوعه جدا
روسيا تقصف العاصمه كلاب ومناطق في الشمال
والجنوب وعينها على صبيانز كريماتوس بعد
سوليداركها باقمار
واتساب وفي ملفات الساعه 6:30 سباقاته
التنافس بين امريكا والصين لا تنتهي
السيارات تتصادق
ب 500 صفحه مشهوره و400 محذوفه الامير
هاري امير المبيعات بكتابه
البريطانيون علي مو اكثر مما تتمناه
[موسيقى]
يناير بدا ساخنا الاوكرانيا ربما ضفوا
الشتاء غير المتوقع هو السبب حمل العام
الجديد استمراريه للاستراتيجيه الروسيه
تدمير البنيه التحتيه ديني بروبيسكي في
كييف خ في الشمال الشرقي وزباروجيا جنوبا
والحراره ترتفع اكثر في الشرق استعراضوا
القوه المتبادله من جهاء التضليل من جهه
اخرى يطفي يعني نكهه خاصه على المعارك
وتحديدا في سوليدار البلده الاستراتيجيه
السيطره عليها من عدمها باتت معركه ابي
حدداتها لكن بكل الاحوال تبدو مساله وقت
باسرار موسكو والتي اكدت بعد ايام من
دعوتها عدم التسرع باعلان النصر في
سوليدار اكد استكمال السيطره على البلده
وانا المرحله التاليه هي بلده سوري خلال
الايام الاربعه الماضيه فقط تجاوزت خسائر
القوات الاوكرانيه في سوليدار 700 جندي
والحصيله وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فبالتالين
فيها الاوكرانيون كما ينفهون سيطره الروس
على المدينه بلوي يؤكدون ان البلدان تحت
سيطره قوات ثياب اصلا رغم اعترافته
السابقه بصعوبه الاوضاع فيها حتى انهم
واثقون من النصر وهكذا تقول الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اما زينسكي فاعتبر ما تروجه
روسيا حول سوليدار في الدعايه
الان تحاول الدوله الارهابيه ومروجوها
التظاهر بان جزءا من مدينه نصر دار الذي
دمره المحتلون بالكامل تقريبا هو نوع من
الانجازات التي حققتها روسيا سيقدمون وهم
يقدمون بالفعل هذا لمجتمعهم من اجل دعم
التعبئه واعطاء الامل لاولئك الذين يؤيدون
العدوان لكن القتال مستمر
[موسيقى]
هذا التقدم الروسي مع قرار اخر مهمه تعيين
قائد جديد للعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
الجنرالريزموف رئيسا للاركان حلا محل سرقه
الذي تولى هذه المهمه قبل ثلاثه اشهر فقط
شبكه
القليل والقصيره الاسلوبكين في المنصب قد
تكون الاجابه في خيبه الامل خلال الاشهر
الثلاثه تباطئت الانتكاسات الروسيه لكنها
لم تتوقع جددها اسلوبكين الهيكل العسكري
في اوكرانيا وامر لبناء خطوط دفاعيه
لابطاء التقدم الالكتروني هل سحب بشكل
منظم من مدينه خرسون الجنوبيه والمناطق
المحيطه بها غربي نهر
الاهداف التي وضعت له وبمعنى اخر بحسب
نيوير تايم حتى انه يتمتع به سمعه جيدا
داخل الجيش الروسي لدرجه انه مؤسس باتمان
يسانده وهو المعارض بقرارات الجيش قال هذا
تمر على تلجرام
الصادق ولديه مبادئ ويثق به الجيش بمن
يمكن مقارنته رغم هذه التصريحات لكن بحسب
واشنطن بوست هناك سبببان رئيسيان لاستبدال
اسبابك وهم عدم تحقيق تقدم في محمود
والاهم ضربه اوكرانيا على مكان
[موسيقى]
مدينه ثانيه تصدرتا الانباء والانباء
المضاده والمتناقضه بين الروس
والاوكرانيين في ماكيفا اعتراف روسي نادر
موسكو اقرت بمقتل 89
عسكريا في المدينه الصناعيه التي تبعد 15
كلم
موسكو قالت انها اعلى بعشره اضعاف روسيا
كان لابد ان ترد
وهنا جاء الهجوم على كروماتورز شمال قالت
روسيا ان قوتها قتلت اكثر من 600 جندي
اوكراني هناك والهجوم تنفيذ وقوعه اصلا
وكثيرا مالجا الطرفان الى التضليل منذ
ذلاع الحرب طالت هجمات اوكرانيا هيبه
روسيا في هجمه طراد مصباح هذا اكبر مثال
السفينه اغرقت ان احترقت في كل الاحوال
ضرب العمود الفقري البحريه الروسيه وعلى
بعد 700 و30 كلم الجنوب شرقيه موسكو طالت
المسيارات الاوكرانيه احد اهم القواعد
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه وهنا نتحدث عن قاعده
انجلش هذه القاعده التي استهدفت اكثر من
مره هي قاعده الثالوث النووي لروسيا
القاذفات الاستراتيجيات الثقيله تتركز هنا
اكتوبر لم يكن السهلا على الروس ولاسيما
على الرئيس بوتن وهو يشاهد الجسر القرم او
جسر كارش الاستراتيجي يشتعل بعمليه تفجير
مركبه مفخخه لان الهزيمه ليست خيارا
بالنسبه له اختار بوتا حلا اخر جعل الوقت
يلعب ضد اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه تؤكد
السيطره على سوليدار في محور محمود يعني
السيطره على البوابه الجنوبيه في عنقي
دنيا
في اوكرانيا مجددا لكنها تعترف هذه المره
الوضع صعب
في اوكرانيا تتركز المعركه في ثلاثه محاور
رئيسيه ضخمه التي تؤكد اوكرانيا صلابه
دفاعتها هناك وهو ما اجبر الروس على تغيير
خططهم العسكريه والاكتفاء بحصارها وهنا
تاتي اهميه السوليدار حيث ركزت قوات او
فاجنر جهودها عليها لقطع الامداد واحكام
حصار باقون اقر بصعوبه الاوضاع هناك خاصه
طرق الامداد التي باتت في مرمى نيرانوس
سوليدار تمثل اهميه استراتيجيه للدفاع عن
بعض كما هو الحال للمدن الكبرى المتبقيه
تحت سيطره الاوكرانيين داخل الحدود
الاداريه لمقاطعه الدنيا
مهام جديده صعبه امام القوات الروسيه الان
وهي السيطره على مدينتي سياسكو اكرامي خط
الدفاع الرئيسي للقوات الاوكرانيه تحقق
القوات الروسيه اختراقات كبيره في خط
الدفاع في دمباز ونجاحات حاسمه في ضخمه
وسيلر وهي نقاط استراتيجيه مهمه تحاول
القياده الاوكرانيه الاحتفاظ بها باي ثمن
كان تعتبر موسكو ان هزيم تركيا في كرامات
لن تكون عسكريه فقط وانما سياسيه ونفسيه
ايضا
معركه وبخمود قد تنقل الروس الى اهداف
استراتيجيه اخرى والسيطره على السوليدار
هي الوسيله سته اشهر وعمر المعركه في
بخموث مرته بمرحلتين الاولى دامت لمئات
يوما قاتل فيها الجيش الروسي التقليدي لكن
نتائجها لم تكن كما تريد موسكو اما
الثانيه سجلت نقطه فارغه في الحرب حين
تولت مجموعه القتال هناك باتت المرحله
اكثر دمويه استعنت فاجنر بسجناء ومرتزقه
وبعد دخولك نار اعلنت روسيا ان الهدف
الرئيسي لا تصليدار وليس محمود السيطره
على سوليدار تساعد اصلا في تطبيق محمود
خاصه وان الاوكرانيين مع خسارهم في البلده
جلبوا
مؤسسه شركه باكناري
المقرب من بوتن يريد اثبات ان شركته هي
الوحيده القادره على تحقيق انجازات عسكريه
بالاساس غير مقتنع عن با وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه واتهامها مرارا بالتقصير خاصه بعد
الانسحاب روسي من خطاب واستعاده
الاوكرانيين السيطره على خرسون يريد
بروجين الانتصار في بخموط وسوليدار لتعزيز
مكانته السياسيه في روسيا وهكذا تتحدث
التقارير الغربيه كما يريد ثروات المدينه
مدينه الملح وتقدر الاحتياطات هناك بنحوي
13 مليار تونس نفرج هذا الامر لكن يبدو ان
عينه تقع على ما هو اكثر من ذلك
ايطالي
ا قبل قليل الوقت يلعب ضد اوكرانيا وهي
كذلك وجهه نظر امريكيه نقلتها نيويورك عن
وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه الصابغه ووزير
الدفاع الامريكي الاسماك روبرتغيتس
المسؤولان الامريكيان السابقان طلبات دول
النيتو بيتزا من عسكريا اكبر لاوكرانيا
رغم ان اجمالي المساعدات الغربيات العام
الماضي بلغ 120 مليار دولار ومن بينها
اكثر من 24 مليار دولار مساعدات عسكريه
امريكيه تطور المعارك في مخ موت وصفه لدار
لصالح الروس زادت من دعاوى تسليح اوكرانيا
ولكنها قد تؤجل بعض الدعم من جهه اخرى فا
ايطاليا مثلا لن تتخذ اي قرار بتقديمي
مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا قبل فبراير
المانيا ايضا ليس لديها خطط لارسال دبابات
وايضا ان كانت تفكر بريطانيا لم تقرر بعد
ارسال دبابات تشالنجر ان كان سيلينز كي
اكد الامر اليوم لكن هذا الامر يعني ان
المواجهه مع روسيا مستقبلا قد تكون ورده
وارده رايس وجيتس يؤكد ذلك وهنا يجب على
الناتو دعم اوكرانيا باسلحه ثقيله ونوعيه
للحد من قدره روسيا في مواجهه الكبرى
محتمله لكن تبقى معضله اخرى تواجه القوات
الاوكرانيه الاسلحه الغربيه العامله في
الجبهات كلمه فعليات الثقيله مثلا هذه هي
المنظمات المعقده تحتاج الى عمليات اصلاح
وصيانه متكرره لكثافه استخدامها وعمليات
الصيانه لا تتم الا على بعد مئات الاميال
من الجبهات وتحديدا في دول النيته يعني
غيابها عن ساحات القتال في وقت طويل مثلا
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا بصيانه
الاسلحه المتبرع بها لاوكرانيا في بولندا
واضافه الى اسبانيا التي تبعد عن جبهه
خيرسون اكثر من الفا 24 وخمسين كيلو مترا
اختلال التوازن عسكريا اكثر ما يخشاه
الاوكرانيون ندركه سيلنسكي جيدا وسيناريو
يصب في صالح روسيا وقد يطيل الحرب اختلال
مطلق لاوكرانيا وحلفائها يراهن عليه بوتن
الا مسيره الايرانيه الصنع شهيد مئه وست
136 تستنزف الدفاعات الاوكرانيه مصيره ب
20,000$ كيف بصواريخ ارض جو ب 500,000
دولار على الاقل لكن لكل صاروخ وهي تكلفه
تحاول اوكرانيا تجنبها وبالمسيرات ايضا
ياتي حلا اوكرانيا تحديدا لهذه المسيره ما
بك ثلاثه الصينيه صغيره وعمره بطاريتها
مناسبه كيف تحاول التصنيع القنبله
المثاليه بداخل هذه المسيره قنابل رخيصه
الدبابات الروسيه
التي تكلف الملايين فرق المسيرات
الاوكرانيه تحاول جعل وزن القنبله نصف
كيلوغرام نصف كيلو جرام وهو اكبر وزن يمكن
ان تحمله المسيره دون ان يشكل ذلك عبئا
اوجهدا عليها كما يستخدمونها طابعه ثلاثيه
الابعاد في محاوله لصنع غلاف قنبله خفيف
الوزن والهدف الرئيسي هو ان تكون قادره
على حمل متفجرات اللي ازمه اختراق الدرع
الدبابه مسيرته ثلاثه الصينيه ماتت العمود
الفقري لقوات الطائرات من دون طياره
الاوكرانيه مزعجه للروسي يمكن هذا ضرب
الاهداف والعوده والمهم تكلفتها اقل من
2000 دولار مقارنه
بالمسيرات الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
اعمل موسكو للمزيد ينضم الينا المحلل
العسكريه السرجه اهلا بك اذا هذه الانباء
والانباء المضاده التي تصدرتها سوليدار
لماذا هذا التاكيد من الجانب الروسي النفي
من الجانب الاوكراني طوال الفتره الماضيه
حول هذه البلده
مساء الخير واطيب تحياتي من موسكو
التطورات الميدانيه الاخيره ولا سيما ما
جرى في مدينه سوليدار لها عند تبعاته
مدينه الاداره بحد ذاتها ليست لها اي
اهميه استراتيجيه مع عدا همم مناجم الملح
هي ااه مصدر لاكثر من 20% من الملح في همم
في اسواق عالميه همم ولكن
عسكريه همم
على بلده سوليدار يفتح التاريخ الى
الدفاعي الاوكراني استراتيجي الثاني
فيشكل خطوره مباشره لما تبقى من القوات
الالكترونيه في ضخمود
لان الان كل طرق الامدادات يعني كل
التامين اللوجستي لتلك القوات صار تحت
النيران المباشر للمدفعيه ابو سليم
الاوكرانيه ولكن في نفس الوقت لو عدنا الى
هذا التناقض ربما او الى هذا التضارب ايضا
كان هناك تضارب في الجانب الروسي الروسي
بمعنى اا قال الاعتراف بان قوات بارنار هي
التي
تتصدر هذه المعركه وان كان كذلك رغم ذلك
اعترفت اعترفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوم
بذلك وقالت ان قوه فاجنر لها الفضل في هذه
السيطره ولكن هذا يفتح الباب للتساؤل حول
الجبهات الاخرى ايضا في همم اوك يعني على
جانب الجيش الروسيه هل هذا لهذه الدرجه هي
عصيه على السيطره
التصريح الاخير الصادر من وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه يؤكد وبكل وضوح ان التقدم في بلده
سوليداير والاستلاع عليها بالكامل
تم بفضل الجهود المشتركه حيث قامت مجموعه
داخل المدينه يعني مالك الشوارع مع
التنسيق مع القوى الجويه وقوات الدفاعيه
وقوات الانزال الجوي الروسيه التي تتوقت
المدينه الشمال والجن
وما نعت كل ما حوالات طرف المعادي لفك
الحصار او الشان الهجوم المضاد فله هناك
اي تناقض بين مجموعه
وزاره الدفاع لانه كلهم همم يشكلون القوات
المسلحه الروسيه
وحدات في معركه سوليدار غير وحدات اتفا
على العموم هناك ايضا هذه النظره لتغيير
القياده قياده الحرب في اوكرانيا ونحن
نتحدث عن قائد جديد خلال ثلاثه اشهر
لم يفسح الجنرال سولاريكين بل اصبح نائبا
لقائد العماليه وقائد العمريه الجديد هو
الجنرال جراسم الذي بنفس الوقت يحل همم
منصب رئيس رئيس
هيئه الاركان الاسلام هذا دليل على ان
وشبابك انسان نايبو وقائد القوات البريه
ايضا اصبحنا ايضا لقائد العماري وهو رئيس
اركان نهايه الاركان العامه هذا كله يدور
على ان صلاحيات القائد الجديد يعني
الجنرال جلاكسي اوسع بكثير من الجنرال
سولاريكان
منصبه الاساسي هو قائد القوى الجويه
والقوات الفضائيه بينما همم تحت يد جد
كل همم
العسكريه الروسيه بما فيها قوات حارس
الحدود والحرس الوطني والقوات الخاصه
الحرب بشكل سيء
ابدا ابدا بلادنا اول شيء ثلاثه اشهر ليس
لديه الفتره يمكن واحد يخيم
فاعليات هذا واحد فاديا اللي هو كانت
الاداره سيئه فيتم اعفاض ضابط او تغيير
تغيير منصبه الى ادنى مستوى الى اخره
بينما همم سوري لا يزال قائد للجيش للقوات
الجويه وهو النائب
لقائد العمليه ليس هناك اي اقوى بالاضافه
لك كما قلت قائد القوات البريه ايضا نائب
رئيس هيئه العامه بالاضافه الى فريق وهو
نائم الاول رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه يعني
هناك همم خيرت القاده وهذا كل ده يدل على
ان لطاقه كلام على سوف يكون اقوى اقوى
والتنسيق احسن
ماسكه المحلله العسكري سيرجي
99 دقيقه لم تشهدها الولايات المتحده منذ
هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مهما حاول المرشدنا
نفسها عن الاحداث بالعثله او الخلوه في
الاشهر الاربعه الماضيه الثانيه ومهما او
عذاب تشتيت الانتباه عن النظر الى الداخل
بتحركات الخارجيه لم تكن هناك حيله تخفي
حملات الاعتقال والقتل او ما يدفع
بالمواقف الدوليه لعدم الالتفات اليها
اجبرها خامنئي في نهايه المطاف على الدخول
الى قلب الاحداث الاسبوع الماضي او ادخال
الاحداث الى دائره دائره الثوره رفض
المرشد استهداف غير المحجبات بالكامل
وفجاه الكثيرين
لا لا ما جلال التشويه والشبهه انه واجب
شرعي وينبغي الالتزام به ولكن اللواتي لا
يلتزمين بالحجاب الكامل لا يجوز التهامهن
باللاديين ومعاداه دائره الثوره
على الشاشه شكلها ايه الله الخميني لمجلس
الثوره 14 رجلا وواحد منهم فقط هو الذي
بقي واستمر وظل موجوده من يكون
والدائره اليوم ربما ينوي اعاده تشكيلها
بسبب انتفاضه يخشاها ضده وبقرارنا متناقض
مع تصريحاته يعين رجل شديدا معروفا بتشدده
ضد النساء غير الملتزمات بالحجاب كقائد
جديد للشرطه احمد رضا رضا
وهناك انقسام داخل دائره خمنائي الامنيه
حيث راى البعض ان القائد السابق حسين
اشتري المتقاعس ولا يستخدم القوه اللازمه
لفض الاحتجاجات خامنئي وبخه قبل اقامه
وبين التصريح المفاجئ والتعيين الجديد
تناقضا يعكس حجم الصراعات بين مراكز القوى
الدائره ستتاثر اكثر لكن على الاقل لا
يخفى الان ان المرشد يحاول ترغيب الجيل
الجديد بدخول دائرهته لكن هل مطالب الجيل
زد الثائر محصوره فقط بالحجاب سنعود الى
هذه النقطه لكن هل تقتصر الازمه بالهوه
بين الجيلين في المعادله الايرانيه الضغوط
للتغيير للقلب المعادله اكبر من فجوه
جيلين الاكراد والبلوش هم اكثر سكان
مشاركه في الاحتجاجات والشعوب غير
الفارسيه اصلا تشكل 60% من السكان لا
شعارات قوميه او مذهبيه خلال الاحتجاجات
كلها موجهها ضد خامن ونظامه
الله اكبر
من السنه وهذا ما يفسر مهاجمه النظام
لمولوي عبد الحميد زعيم السنه الذي يصعد
بين الحين والاخر التصريحاته ضد النظام
لكن رغم ذلك الاعلام الحكومي الايراني
بنفسه يحاولون تخويف المواطنين دائما من
النزعه الانفصاليه خرج الخامنائي قبل ايام
ليحذر من الاختلافات المذهبيه والقوميه
اسلام دربارين نظام هناك وحده في الراي
بين الناس حول الاسلام وحول الثوره لا
تدعو هذه الوحده في الراي تختفي لا تدعم
الخلافات كالاختلافات العرقيه والاختلافات
المذهبيه وتحريض مشاعر مجموعه ضد مجموعه
اخرى
لكن الخلافات التي يحذر خامنئي منها
موجوده اصلا داخل دائرته لا توجد
استراتيجيه واحده للتعامل مع تظاهرات
طارتنا تصريحات من خامنئي باحترام المراه
الايرانيات وتارتا بتعيينه لقاء جديد
للشرطه لمراقبه الحجاب كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
باطلاقه شخصيات بارزه في الانتفاضه مثل
لما جئت توكلي وحسين روقي والطيره بزياده
عمليات الاعدام الانقسامات الانعكاسون
للتناقدات تغيير اخر النظام قد يستغني عن
سكرتير المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي علشان
تنقلته شبكه خبر السابعه لهيئه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون الايراني وبالمناسبه ايران
اليوم حكم الاعدام الذي اصدرته على احد
المقربين من شمخاني علي رضا اكبر احد
المسؤولين السابقين في وزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه والتهمه التجسس لصالح بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
يخشى الخيانه ويلجا اليها كحجه في كثيرا
من الاحيان لكن اكثر ما يخيف النظام الان
لا يعرف عنه الكثير الجيل زد وراء توجيهي
وادامه موجه الاحتجاجات الاخيره وهي التي
لم يتداركها مثل ما فعل في انتفاضات
الكبرى سيطره عليها في الاعوام الخمسه
الماضيه الشجاعه والمثابره الثانيه يتحلى
بهما هؤلاء اكبر من طاقه السلطات على
الاستيعاب ابناء العالم الافتراضي كما
يطلق عليهم
مراهقين وشبابا بل اكثر من ذلكم نحو 18
مليون من اصل 90 مليون ايراني بحسب مركز
الاحصاء الرسمي
24 مليون تقريبا تبلغ اعمارهم 25 عاما
وحتى 39 وكثيرا من المطالبه تتقاطع بين
لكن النظام
وجود نوعا من الغدر في رغبه الجنس صدق في
التعاطي مع العالم الخارجي غير انهم ليسوا
وحدهم ب 84% من الايرانيين باتوا يتمتعون
بامكانيات الوصول الى الانترنت بحلول عام
2020 الفرق هو ان الجلسد صوته اعلى
وذاكرته لا تحمل امجاد ثوره الخميني
والخوف منها بل هي مثقله بازمات اقتصاديه
السياسيه قمع وتكميم للافواه وازكاه
للموسيقى والفن وكل ما هو لا يتناسب مع
صوره النظام الانعزال الرافد للاخر
جيلوا الانترنت كما يسميه النظام تمثل له
الامل في اقمار ستيرلينغ الصناعيه في ظل
يضيق خناق الحريه لكن هل فعلا تحل ستار
لينك مشكله حسب الانترنت هو قطعيه في عموم
البلاد كلما انه نظام ذلك
هي حل لتوفير الانترنت لكن في الحاله
الايرانيه الهدف بالغ التعقيد لا فائده من
هذا القمر دون هذا الطبق صغيرا بحجم طبقي
بيتزا والازمه ليست في دخوله الى ايران
رغم ان ذلك يتم عن يتم عن طريق التهريب
المنافذه مو صادق بقوه استنفر حرس الحدود
للتفتيش لكن بحسب صاحبه
تهريب الاطباق الى داخل يشرف عليها نشطاء
من الخارج مجموعه نشطاء امريكيين من اصل
ايراني ورجال الاعمال في قطاع التكنولوجيا
في ولايه كاليفورنيا احنا تعبروا من
العراق رئيس نقابه الاجهزه اجهزه
الاتصالات في طيران مهدي محبين صرح بان
عدد الاطباق التي تم تهريبها وصل الى 800
طبق او جهاز ان كان العدد صحيحا وحتى ان
كان الضعف فلن يحقق فارقا في از وصول
الايرانيين الى انترنت غير مقيد والمشكله
ليست التقنيه بل هي بسيطه تقنيه يوضع
الطبق على سطح منزل لجلب شبكه الانترنت من
على بعد 550 كلم حيث تدور 100 قمر تغطي
نطاق ايران الجغرافي وبالمناسبه
89% منهم يستخدمون انستغرام 40 مليون
يستخدمون تليجرام هو شعب نشط تكنولوجيا
وبالطبع الانشط هم العشرون مليون شاب
وشابه جيل سد الايراني ومن اوجد لهم من
مخرجه من قيود النظام
[موسيقى]
مجالات التنافس الصيني الامريكيه لا تنتهي
هذه المره اداه التجسس جديده قد تكون انت
من يمتلكها مع ملايين البشر حول العالم
ونتحدث هنا عن السيارات وتحديدا
الكهربائيه ذاتيه القياده القلق الامني
يحيى لوسيله نقل جديده ليس بجديد قبل قرن
تحديدا في عام 1913 صادر الجيش الفرنسي من
فضاء الاسد اربعه الالماني باريس امرت
بمصادره اي صور لمواقعها المحصنه اليوم
باتل امر اكثر تعقيدا بيانات عن مكالمات
السائق وتاريخ تصفحه الانترنت
لاحقا يمكن ان تستخدمها الشركه المصنعه
بعدها ظاهرها لتحسين اعوام الامن والسلامه
لكن في الباطن يمكن نقلها للخارج وهو ما
تخشاه واشنطن وايضا بكين والاخيره صنفت
الامر في 2017
كتهديدا للامن القومي سهوله واختراقيه
الشبكات الرابطه لهذا النوع من السيارات
هاجس اخر وحقيقه اثبتها العام الماضي
مبرمج الماني عمره 19 عاما سيطر على اكثر
من 20 سياره تسلا في عشر دول مختلفه وقتها
كان بامكانه تشغيل السيارات وتعطيل انظمه
الامن وتحميل جميع المعلومات المتعلقه
بموقع ومسار وتاريخ رحلات السياره
ديك توك الى هواوي والجيل الخامس الى
المركبات ذاتيه القياده الصينيه او ما
يعرف بالفيز اجتياح غير مسبوق للصين
للاراضي الامريكيه الامر الذي استدعى على
رحاله الطوارئ من قبل بعض المشجعين
الامريكيين من امكانيه تهديد الامن القومي
الامريكي واعتبار هذه التقنيات الصينيه
بما ثابت حصان طرواده مصارعون امريكيون
قدموا مشاريع تشريعيه تحدوا من جمع
الشركات الصينيه معلومات حساسه عن البنيه
التحتيه الامريكيه بما في ذلك معلومات حول
المنشات الحكوميه العسكريه ونقلبها الى
بكيين بالاضافه الى تشريعه تحكم الامن
السيبراني للمركبات ذاتيه القياده
المصارعون الديمقراطيون والجمهوريون شددوا
على ضروره التصرف بسرعه لضمان عدم السماح
للمركبات ذاتيه القياده بان تصبح مصدرا
اخر للبيانات المستخدمه ضد المصلحه
الوطنيه للولايات المتحده من قبل الصين
قلقوا بكين وواشنطن من خطوره استخدام
السيارات الكهربائيه كشواسيس متحركه انعكس
عبر سلسله قوانين طلب بها مشرعون او بدا
العمل بها بالفعل في مارس 2001 2021 اصدرت
السلطات الصينيه قرارا بمنع دخول سيارات
تسلا الى مقارات المباني الحكوميه
والمؤسسات الحساسه كما اجبرت تسلا على فتح
مركز البيانات لتخزين جميع البيانات في
سياراتها في الصين نحن في العام ذاته لكن
في يونيو
بكين اي سياره تسلم من السير في منتجع
بدايه في اقليم لمده شهرين وما هو السبب
المنتجع كان مقر التجمع السنوي للمسؤولين
الحاليين والسابقين في الحزب الشيوعي
بعدها باسبوعين تكرر الامر في مدينه شندو
وهذه المره السبب زيارته الرئيس
فتاخرت عن بكين في تشريع القوانين ربما
للشغاله هذه سيه واوي وتكتوك لكن ان تاتي
متاخرا خيرا من الا تاتي اصلا الجمهوريون
بداوا في الضغط على اداره السلامه على
الطرق السريعه لفرض قيود على السيارات
الصينيه وربما اغلبيتهم من مجلس النواب
يساعد ان تنافس قائم على التفوق في صناعه
السيارات الذكيه ذاتيه القياده ايضا
والافضليه مع بكين التي تتفوق في معدن
الكباب وبطريات الليثيوم وحتى ان بعض
التقديرات الامريكيه تشير الى ان حصه
السيارات الكهربائيه والذاتيه القياده
الصينيه في السوق الامريكيه قد تصل
مستقبلا الى 10% من اجمالي عدد المركبات
في الولايات المتحده
القلق الامريكي يبدو مشروعا فالامر تكرر
مع دوله اخرى وهنا نتحدث عن بريطانيا قبل
ايام تم اكتشافه جهازي تتبع صينيا مخفيا
في سياره تابعه للحكومه البريطانيه لندن
قلقه على الامن القومي وكذلك واشنطن التي
بدا خلقها يتزايد اكثر بعد السماح لشركه
اوتو اكس الصينيه باجراء تجارب للسيارات
ذاتيه القياده في شوارع سان فرانسيسكو
السياره الصينيه حالها كحالي تسلم مزوده
بثمانيه كاميرات محيطات توفر رؤيا بزاويه
360 درجه لاشارات المرور وعلامات الاشاره
والمنحدرات والحواجز وغيرها من المعلومات
كما تستخدم الشركه الصينيه تقنيه اللي دار
التي تخلت عنها تسلم مؤخرا تستخدم لاكتشاف
الضوء وتحديد المدى ويستخدم هذا النوع من
اجهزه الاستشعار نبضات ضوئيه لت معلومات
ثلاثيه الابعاد دقيقه حول محيطها
وتستطيع سيارات ذاتيه القياده الوصول
لمعلومات سائقها وهنتحدث هنا عن تاريخ
وتفاصيل تصفح الانترنت والبريد الالكتروني
والرسائل القصيره الى جانب الجهاد الاتصال
والعناوين التي تذهب اليها وبصمات اصابعك
او اكتشاف الوجه
والواثق به بعيدا كلاهما في مرمى النيران
في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
قبل لحظه الفوضى هذه في الواقع ما حدث يوم
الاربعاء الماضي وان كان لم يستمر
عنده حدث تاريخيا في الولايات المتحده في
هذا الوقت القصير ليس في عالم الملاحه
الجويه اكثر من 1300 رحله
وعشره
الافرار في الحقيقه وهي لا تذكر مقابل
سيناريو اقلاع وهبوط الطائرات دون النظام
كانت لتكون هذه الطائرات عمياء ولذلك قرار
تعليق حركه الملاحه كما صائبا والكلام هنا
ليكي
وزير النقل الامريكيه الذي يواجه مازدا
حاليا وسنعود اليه بعد قليل
النظام ينبه الطيارين والمطارات لمش
بالسلامه يعنى بالجليد على المدارس وحتى
باسراب الطيور في اجواء الهبوط والاقلاع
للطائرات ولما خذ كثيرا في تقنيه النظام
الذي انشا قبل اكثر من نصف قرن وتطور من
نسخته الورقيه الى هذا الشكل فا الاهم هو
انه يتحكم في الملاحه الامريكيه والعالميه
بالتالي
25,000 رحله جويه تحمل مليونين و300,000
مسافر من والى ما يقرب من 80 دوله
و66 من البضائع من والى اكثر من 200
وعشرين دوله هذا النظام الضابط لكل هذه
الحركات لما يحدث منذ عام 2015 اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه هي المسؤوله ربما غير
ان الكونغرس في وجهه النظر المعاكسه لم
يدعم الاداره باموال تكفي للقيام ببطئها
العديده بشكل صحيح خبراء يرون ان ميسانيه
ساره التي بلغت 18 مليون ونصف المليون
دولار في عام 2022 هي اقل من تلك المخصصه
في 2004 مع احتساب التضخم لا تسمح بتغيير
وتحديث انظمه الطيران الامريكي حتى انها
السبب وراء التدخل تاخر عفوا نظام النكس
جان الذي اطلقه الكونغرس قبل عقدين لاصلاح
شامل لنظام الطيران الوطني في الميزانيه
مليار دولار سنويا هذا النظام تاخر عن
موعده كثيرا رغم انها كانت
90 دقيقه فقط لكن التوقف الكامل لقطاع
الطيران عاد للذاكره هجمات الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر عام 2001 ما حدث هو الاول من نوعه
منذ ذلك الوقت هذه الدقائق التسعين جعلت
وزيرا نقل الامريكي فيث بوتوجيج في مرمى
نيران لم يصل منها اصلا منذ توليه المنصب
قبل عامين عام 2021 ازمه لسلسله التوريد
العالميه المرتبطه بجائحه كورونا والتي
ادت لاضطرابات هائله في الموانئ الامريكيه
في يوليو الغيت شركات الغد شركات الطيران
الافراح اطالب الديمقراطيون انفسهم باصلاح
في اوائل ديسمبر العام الماضي الطير
الكونجرس للتدخل لتجنب اضراب لقطاع الشحنه
بالسكك الحديديه بسبب الاجور اما في نهايه
ديسمبر فالغت سوفت اير 9 الاف الرحلات
الجويه بعد عاصفه ضربت اجزاء كثيره من
البلاد ثم اتت ازمه الاربعاء ولان بوتاجاز
الديمقراطي فنيران التي يواجهها جمهوريه
الجمهوريون وبسبب كل هذه الازمات اتهموه
بانه غير كفى وغير مؤهل لمنصبه وعلى راسهم
تذكروز السنه الجمهوري العضو في اللجنه
التي تشرف اصلا على وزاره النقل وامام هذا
الهجوم الجبوري فالدفاع طبعا ديمقراطيه
ومن راس الهرم الرئيس
فيسبوك
مؤثر على وثائق سريه في منزلي بيضا وفي
مكتبه كان يستخدمه بعد مغادره منصبه كنا
ابن اوباما للي يعين النائب العام
الامريكي مستشفى
رئاسه ترامب اذا هناك ضغط على وجود مجلس
نواب يسيطر عليه الجمهوريون سيجعل هذا
الضغط اكثر شراسه وسيجعل الرئيس الامريكي
في موقفا دفاعي خلال العامين المتبقين
والملفات المستخدمها ضدها
[موسيقى]
سبير او البديل وهذا الاسم اختاره تحديدا
الامير هاري عنوان لكتابه الجديد الذي
يبلغ من العمر 38
في المملكه المتحده الان لانه ابرز كتاب
يتناول العائله الملكيه
الاميره ديانا هيرتوري عام 1992 والكتاب
بصفحاته ال 500 المنشوره وصفحاته 400
المحذوفه ولغته 16 التي ترجم اليها
بنسختها الصوتيه بات الان في الاسواق بعد
تسريبات ومقابلات حوله لكن لماذا اثار كل
هذا
هذه يكشف في الكتاب كواليس ما دار منذ
تخليه عن مهامه الملكيه في عام 2020 بعد
زواجه بعمل من الممثله الامريكيه مدام
ماركل وانتقالهما الى كاليفورنيا لبدا
حياه جديده
[موسيقى]
الابرز في الكتاب علاقه هاري ويليام علاقه
متوتره والسبب في ذلك ميغان بطله من ابطال
مسلسل الاسود الشهير في عام 2019 امسك
وليام بياقتي ومزق قلادتي وطرحاني على
الارض هكذا يتحدث هاري في كتابه الجديد عن
شجار دار مع اخيه لكن لماذا الشجار ولما
كان ينتقد زواج هاري من مكانها قبل سنه من
ذلك وتحديدا عام 2018 وكان يصفها بالصعبه
والفضه والواقحه الشجرات استمر بين فاقى
اشقاء ودفعت والدهما عام 2021 بالوقوف بين
هاري وليم طالبا منهما عدم جعل سنواته
الاخيره بالبائسه في هذا الوقت تحديدا عاد
هاري الى بريطانيا للمره الاولى منذ تخليه
عن ادواره بالعائله الملكيه وذلك من اجل
حضور الجنازه جده الامير ورغم هذه
الخلافات يؤكد هاري انه ارسل رساله نصيه
وليام يسالها فيها ان كان سيذهب وزوجته
كيت لي قصر بلورل حيث كانت الملكه تحتضر
هناك لكنه وليم لم يرد ما رد هو الوالد
تشارلز وانت مرحب بك يا هاري لكنها زوجتك
فلا وربما هذا يفسر اتهام هاري في كتابه
للامير تشارلز بانه يشعر بالغيره من زوجته
ليست فقط وانما من كانت مثل
زوجه الامير ويليام
من مليون و400 الف نسخه تم بيعها في اليوم
الاول من اصدار كتاب الامير هاري الذي طال
انتظاره لتصبح النسخه الانجليزيه منه سبير
الاسرع مبيعا في فئه الكتب غير الروائيه
في العالم وتضمن الاصدار الرسمي للكتاب في
العاشر من يناير مع عده مقابلات
التلفزيونيه اعطاها هاري لوسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه والبريطانيه صاروا الكتاب سبقته
تسريبات من نسخه اسبانيه طرحت في الاسواق
بالخطا وهو ما منح الكتاب فرصه تسويقا غير
متوقعه تحدث هاري عن مشاركته في قتل خمسه
وعشرين عنصر من طالبان ما اثر ردود فعلا
مقلقه اذا شار خبراء في مجال مكافحه
الارهاب الى ان تصريحاته وضعته هو وافراد
عائلته تحت خطر الاستهداف كما تحدث عن
شجار الحاج مع اخيه وليام ولي العهد
الحالي الى جانب اعترافه بتعطي الكوكايين
خلال التي شباب ووضع هاري والده واخاه في
موقف محرج بعد كشفه عن تفاصيل علاقته
المنقطعه حاليا معاهما في النهايه الخلاصه
الاساسيه التي اجمع عليها كثيرون النهاري
امير المبيعات اعطى الناس اكثر من مكانه
يتمنون معرفته
مشاهدينا بذلك نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
الساعه ولكن قبل الختام تن تن شخصيه
خياليه كوميديه شهيره ذكرها الفنان
البلجيكي ارشيف في عشرينات القرن الماضي
اليوم يطرح الرسم الاصليه للغلافه
الولايات المتحده
ومع توقعات بان يكون اغلى عملا فنيا خاص
بكتاب الرسوم من الان وحتى الساعه المقبله
انا حنين السوري وهذه الساعه 06
[موسيقى]
سامي